ich habe auch ein thema mitgebracht ich
wollte eigentlich nicht mehr aufgreifen
ich dachte mir nehmen es hin sei
gelassen dann wird es schlimmer ich nahm
es hin ich wollte gelassen es wurde viel
viel schlimmer das habe ich gestern
nämlich gemerkt ich habe den fehler
gemacht ich habe mir ein fernsehduell
angeschaut das fernsehduell zwischen
zwei zwischen herrn und frau le pen das
wurde simultan gedolmetscht und der
deutsche dolmetscher legt herr noch
immer das wort in den mund von den
flüchtenden er hat bestimmt von
flüchtlingen gesprochen aber der
deutsche zuschauer muss natürlich
erzogen werden es sind flüchtende dann
habe ich eine reportage gehört im
bayerischen fernsehen im bayrischen
radio da ging es um streit in der
nachbarschaft und es war immer die rede
von anwohnenden dann dachte ich mir
warum sind ist eigentlich nicht an
wollen dann gibt es nur in bayern an
wohnende nein auch in berlin gibt es an
wohnende und sogar die berliner polizei
twittert mittlerweile von anwohnenden
wir haben auch eine gender sprache mit
sternchen mit unterstrich und kleiner
manchmal auch mit einem mehrfachen kreuz
das heißt man ist von der klarheit in
der benennung übergewechselt in ein
quasi diktatorisches um
erziehungsprogramm einer elite die einer
mehrheit gerne vorschreiben möchte wie
sie zu reden hat besonders absurde höhen
treibt dieses gendern das komplett
unnötig ist bei der außenministerin frau
werber genauer gesagt bei der
kommunikation ihres amtes es gibt heute
nicht mehr kollegen sondern kolleg stern
innen außenminister stern ihnen noch
einmal minister kollegen kunden sind
komplett vollständig es ist kein defizit
es ist nämlich nur ein generisches
maskulinum kein sexuelles und das
besonders tragische und völlig sinnlose
war dann eben bei frau werburg als sie
mehrmals sagte unsere solidarität und
unsere hilfe gelten den menschen in der
ukraine
da dachte ich mir ach ja die russen die
da gerade einmarschiert sind auch
menschen in der ukraine und den gilt
unsere solidarität mein mann sagte
mensch in der ukraine um nicht das böse
wort vom ukraine aussprechen zu müssen
denn der ukraine ist grammatikalisch
männlich und das männliche soll offenbar
zumindest auch der sprache aus gepflegt
werden das ist falsch das ist unredlich
das ist ein um erziehungsprogramm ich
möchte dabei nicht mitmachen ich möchte
nicht dass mich politiker so anreden ich
möchte auch nicht dass die
öffentlich-rechtlichen medien mich so
anreden bitte bitte hört damit auf dann
kann ich wieder meinen seelenfrieden
also ich widerspreche alexander kissler
sehr sehr ungern weil ich es liebe
sondern artikel in der nzz und bin
eigentlich am meisten fällen immer seine
meinung und die schönheit ist dabei doch
und in dem fall will ich natürlich auch
ihrer meinung nur ich glaube dass die
aufregung darüber völlig überflüssig ist
viel lustiger als viel besser ist sich
darüber lustig zu machen denn die partie
tatsache ist doch die diese gender
mainstream aktivisten über drehen gerade
so sehr dass sie sich selbst eine erste
und jeder normale mensch finde das
lächerlich das heißt sich darüber
aufzuregen ist eigentlich überflüssig
wenn man wenn man schon hört an wohnende
ist das doch es ist doch normal beim
sprachgefühl dass er dass das unsinn ist
ich finde auch wenn nicht öffentlich
rechtlichen radio höre muss ich immer
wieder ich finde diese komischen
pause thema gemacht künstler innen also
dass tisch steht die neue binären
menschen ja dass das auch das steht auch
sendezeit auf lamy so das machst du dich
mal zusammen rechnet ausländer verstehen
das ähnlich ausländer oder leute geben
sie der wahrnehmung eingeschränkt sind
verstehen aber wie gesagt ich finde
darüber aufregen ist unsinn weil ich wie
gesagt die das tut das wird derzeit so
überdreht dass sie sich selbst ab so
aber selbst in meinem geld ich sage ja
auch gebühren java führen weil ich
glaube das ist der entscheidende punkt
ich glaube jeder kann und soll irgendwie
sprechen wir wären natürlich das
bachelor also ich finde auch seine
sprache die auch alle menschen mit
einbezieht alles in ordnung aber ich
finde schon wenn man wenn man sieht was
gerade in den öffentlich rechtlichen
medien gerade so im kinderfernsehen ja
da gibt es ja verschiedene programme
also welche sprache dort gesprochen wird
die hat haben sie ein beispiel für uns
ja also gibt es irgendwelche pronomen
gewählt werden
das hat einfach nichts mit deutsch
nichts mehr zu tun und ich also ich muss
sagen vielleicht bin ich auch zu alt
also ich verstehe es nicht ja und ich
würde empfehlen nur da ehrlich gesagt
auch nicht wollen dass man meine tochter
sozusagen mit mit einer solchen
deutschen sprache die es gar nicht gibt
der aktion machen denn danach sendung
mit der maus ist noch zu klein und so
viel habe ich ein problem noch nicht
aber aber das ist schon ein thema wenn
sie ein problem in der zukunft der mit
genau es pflanzt sich ja vor zu sein und
deswegen ist es schon ein thema wo man
sich erstens drüber aufregen kann
vielleicht ich muss aber aufregen kann
aber was schon fertig einer lösung
zugeführt werden muss weil am ende
sprach ist etwas lebendiges das
verändert sich ja und insofern am ende
die schülerin und schüler wissen
irgendwann am ende gar nicht mehr so zu
sagen ich will matschie
exploriert die leute auch das macht eine
kleine sprache und dem gegenüber eine
große menge die als verstockt
dargestellt wird was ist ja auch virtual
signalling also ich rede so toll weil
ich so aufgeklärt bin weil ich kein
ausgrenzen will aber man grenzt alle aus
ich habe jetzt in einem pfarrbrief er in
berlin gelesen liebe mitglieder
mitgliederinnen liebe mitglieder mit
aber doch so komisch dass das ist doch
es gibt schon
warum
haben sie gelassen das freut mich wenn
ich meine frage ein händler zu stellen
kann es denn vielleicht sein dass die
ampel die wahlperiode der umerziehung
wird wahlperiode der umerziehung das
glaube ich nicht das ist auch nicht der
anspruch beispielsweise meiner partei
der fdp also niemand soll umerzogen
werden aber ich will mal hier eine etwas
provokante these in den raum stellen ich
nehme immer wieder war also wenn wir
jetzt hier sozusagen als mittelalte
männer das thema diskutieren dann geben
wir natürlich auch unsere wahrnehmung
unsere werte auch unsere
lebensrealität eben wieder ich nehme
aber war dass die generation nach uns
kommt also gerade sage ich mal sehr
junge menschen auch was die die
geschlechterfrage und die definition
auch das was man wie man sich selbst
definiert und versteht das wesentlich
gelassener sehen als wir beispielsweise
und ich glaube das könnte auch im
hinblick auf den sprachgebrauch gelten
dass da nämlich eine ganz andere
offenheit dafür existiert ich meine
natürlich sie arbeiten mit sprache sie
auch wir als politiker letztlich auch da
ist ein tresor tv natürlichen und
bundeskanzlerin da sind uns ja einig
dass der nicht mit sprache so viele
haben wegen dieser einwurf aber wie
gesagt ich sehe dass wir
bevölkerungskreise haben und gerade bei
jungen menschen sehe ich dass die haben
eine ganz andere offenheit dafür und das
könnte durchaus sein dass wir da
vielleicht nicht ganz richtig aber wir
haben aber
völlig in ordnung wenn es ein
natürlicher prozess ist weil
gesellschaft entwickelt im sommer sich
deswegen auch ford entwickelt das haben
wir in den letzten tausend jahren
natürlich gehabt dann sprachen sich
fortentwickelt hat das finde ich völlig
in ordnung und überhaupt nicht
kritikwürdig aber wenn es oktroyiert
wird von außen operiert wird und wie sie
richtig sagen eine aus einer eliten
sprache sozusagen versucht wird eine
allgemeine sprache zu geben